- I don't know if y'all saw,
'That's My Jam' with miss over here.
- [Kate] Oh, my God.
- [Kelly Clarkson] But I was like,
we're competitive.
- [Kate] Yeah, oh yeah.
- [Kelly] So I love that.
I'm very competitive.
- Well see,
am I competitive?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh, no yeah.
(audience laughs)
The person that asks that-
- Yeah, no, very, very.
- [Kelly] Is totally competitive.
- I literally-
- She's the one screaming
in game nights and stuff.
I mean, I'm like "Kate, it's a game night,
We're supposed
to have a good time-"
- [Kate] And I'm like, "shut up."
- I know.
(audience laughs)
- So all of our-
- Accusations of cheating
all the time.
- After,
the Jimmy Fallon thing
I literally called Dalton and I'm like,
was I nuts?
Like, did I come across
like too competitive?
- This is exactly what I asked my friends
about me when I was on the show.
I was like do I come.
- [Kate] Yeah, I was like-
- Across insane?
- Is it weird?
- Yeah, because something happens.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- And I'm just like-
- [Kelly] Takes over
- Get me in it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know?
And it takes you over completely.
- Yes, but why play?
- But-
- Unless you're gonna compete.
- That's what I say.
(audience cheers)
- You know
- [Kelly] Look at him!
He's out.
- You show up to win.
Not in like a bad-
- No I get it, I get it.
- Like its the end of the world.
- Kate's had game nights forever,
right?
- Oh really?
- First of all-
- Yeah, it's like a thing.
- I never get invited.
- Wait, is that because-
- Which is true.
- It's usually true!
- Yeah because, I'm not
a big enough celebrity
is what I think.
(all laughs)
I really do because-
- That's not true!
- Oh wait, is this because
you're competitive enough?
- No, no, no.
It's because I have fear
when I'm going up against
like Leo DiCaprio.
- Oh god!
- And Tom Hanks and you know.
- No, Oliver, that's ridiculous.
- No, it's true, like Sir
Anthony Hopkins is doing
like running charades.
- You have academy awards...
What?
(all laughs)
I would never wanna play
charades in that company!
- I would do anything for
Sir Anthony Hopkins to do
running charades.
- But I'm serious in that.
Like I have anxiety for
game nights because she
invites very prominent
people who are professionals-
- No, no stop.
- And Academy Award winners.
- Here's the thing, here's the thing
the ruth is that I used to invite him
and he never showed up.
- No.
- So then,
I just stopped inviting him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because he'd never come.
Well, first of all your
wife is always so late.
- I know.
- That the party
would be like done.